[Музика]
о мій боже, пора уроку, боже мій,
давайте почнемо урок так
час уроку привіт усім, настав
час уроку англійської, мене звати Наталія,
авторка,
мене звати olga maja, ласкаво просимо, давайте почнемо,
тому сьогодні ми"  я буду говорити про
посковзування, і я хочу задати вам
питання про те, чи добре ви спали,
ні Наталія, я погано спав минулої
ночі, чому
я випив чашку кави приблизно о 19:00  потім
я почувалася повною енергії, я пішла в спортзал,
я бачу, я дуже добре потренувалася 30-хвилинним тренуванням,
потім я прийшла додому, я була голодна,
тому перекусила, а потім пішла спати,
подумала, чому я перевірила свій обліковий
запис Instagram  і я думав, що провів там лише
п'ять хвилин, але в підсумку я пробув
там близько години.
Вау, схоже, ви зробили все
не так, тому що ті кроки, які ви робите
, неприпустимі перед тим, як ви підете на бій,
о так, я відчував себе дуже сварливим у
вранці я подивився в дзеркало
і побачив тих, кого ви знаєте, втомлені обличчя,
втомлені очі, я взагалі не був щасливий, я бачу
хлопців, тому сьогодні ми зосередимося на
техніці ковзання і тому, як
сон важливий у нашому житті, тому ми '
Буду проходити різні правила, і я сподіваюся,
що сьогодні ви побачите бета-версію
о так добре, давайте почнемо зараз, подивимося на
картинку і спробуємо вгадати,
які числа ви можете побачити Наталія,
шість з десяти, що це означає  виступати за так, щоб
шість підлітків з десяти
насправді не отримували достатньої кількості  ой сон чи можете ви
уявити, що більше половини
підлітків вони погано сплять
вночі як вчителі Я знаю наслідки
цього я бачу, що щодо семи з десяти
сім із десяти старшокласників не
сплять достатньо  коли ти прогресуєш у
навчанні, ти більше вчишся, ти витрачаєш більше
часу на роботу і не спиш
належним чином, тому це прогресуюча цифра,
це недобре, і які
години сну для дорослих і для дітей, тому
для дітей хороші цифри від  дев'ять
-дванадцять годин сну на добу, а для
дорослих це від восьми до десяти,
скільки годин ви зазвичай спите.
Скажу вам правду, я ніколи не сплю навіть
вісім годин, що є мінімально
необхідним, як я бачу, я намагаюся зробити все можливе  сплю
вісім годин, але зазвичай у мене
приблизно від шести до семи, це мій звичайний
день, але для дітей це не так, хлопці,
будь ласка, спробуйте зробити свій дев'ять годин на
вісім годин добре, давайте продовжимо, я
підготував для вас кілька фотографій, які ви
бачите на  екран і ми  я збираюся
викласти їх на дошку зараз, і ми
збираємося разом перевіряти. Я хочу, щоб ви
позначили їх як правильні або
невірні правила, перш ніж йти в бій, добре,
тому давайте перевіримо разом, у мене є два
маркери, для яких правильний  неправильні
дії, а зелений для хороших
дій, тому я б хотів, щоб ви позначили
ці правила як неправильні або правильні, тож чи
можете ви поставити галочку або хрестик так дуже
добре давайте почнемо, і ви перевірте у нас,
це виглядає як будильник, який встановлює
будильник  годинник - це хороша ідея, чи не так
добре, тому я б поставив зелену галочку, добре,
давайте продовжимо ми
в легкій книзі, перш ніж стане погано,
добре це чи погано виглядає, як це гарна ідея,
погодьтеся, фантастично
носити маску - це гарна ідея  або погана
ідея, як ви думаєте, що я читав
статтю, в якій сказано, що
для нас дуже важливо спати в цілковитій
темряві,
але іноді кімнати не дуже
темні, тож я б погодився.
легкий перекус перед походом до но і
ці ко  Ви погано спите, тому хлопці,
які легко перекусують, добре це чи погано,
це виглядає смачно, але я вважаю, що це
погана ідея
так, не їсти перед сном, за
скільки годин до сну я
маю останній прийом їжі принаймні за три  годин
до того, як стане погано, давайте випиймо
склянку води, чи корисно це
перед сном, як ви думаєте, я вірю, що
склянка води не зашкодить, тому я
б пішла випити склянку води, я погоджуюся, що
це дуже  гарна ідея, а як щодо
чашки кави. З мого досвіду я
можу сказати вам правду, що
ви не повинні пити каву
вдень, фантастично, я абсолютно погоджуюся
з вами
без кави перед сном, але
яка причина не пити каву, тому що
кава  у вас багато кави, яка
заряджає вашу енергію. Вау, я б пила
її лише вранці, а уникала ввечері
годин фантастичний, це хороша порада,
давайте підемо зі шторами, чи скористаєтеся ви
шторами або шторами в кімнаті
, щоб приховати місячне світло чи все,
що у вас є на вулиці, чи ні так,
як я сказав вам у статті, яку я  Я
прочитав пропозицію мати штори
та закривати жалюзі
якомога сильніше так, це гарне правило, добре,
тому останнє правило: тримати світло
в кімнаті чи добре вимикати, я
думаю, ви його вимкнутимете, і
знову стаття  розповіли про розумні
будинки, де ви можете запрограмувати своє освітлення,
і через певну годину вони
темніють, добре,
фантастично, тому я думаю, що ми готові з
усіма правилами, тепер, хлопці, ви бачите
правильні відповіді на екрані, тому давайте
підсумуємо правильні дії та п’яні
дії  ви мені добре допомагаєте тепер,
коли ми зробили цю прекрасну справу
, легко уникнути стресу, якщо
вам потрібно прокидатися вранці і
хто боїться, що ви можете проспати, скористайтеся
будильником або ви також можете організувати свою
дев'ятку  мені було б добре, якби ви
лягали спати в один і той же час, якщо ви прокидаєтеся в один і
той же час, щоб ви влаштували свої
звички спати, не змішуйте ці години,
будь ласка, вам буде легше
так, читати легку книгу, мабуть,
дуже багато  краще, ніж те, що я зробив із
Instagram фільмів у Великобританії, тому уникайте використання
різних пристроїв перед сном
добре добре маска
так маска для сну допомагає у догляді намагайтеся
не їсти важкого
обіду трохи перекусити може вам допомогти, але пам’ятайте,
що три  годин перед
сном не потрібно їсти, пити
воду, не кашляти, ні каву,
вимкнути світло і закрити штори
або штори, тепер ти можеш бачити правильні
і неправильні дії на екрані
Наталія, пам'ятає, що ти нещодавно створила
пост про гігієну сну, але я не
встиг нічого прочитати про те, що
гігієна сну – це різноманітні
методи та звички, які необхідні
для хорошої якості нічного сну та
повної денної пильності, тож давайте поговоримо
про гігієну сну  ene і давайте створимо
плакат хлопці для гігієни сну
давайте Ольга ми будемо малювати плакат
а ти малюй з нами
[Музика]
тому подивіться основні правила сну
на екрані молодці давайте далі
зараз Китай ти продовжуєш говорити про
важливість сну, але що він
насправді може покращити, тож, хлопці, давайте
закінчимо речення сон у гігієні може
покращити те, що він може покращити, перш за все
це може покращити вашу продуктивність, ви
працюєте краще, коли ви спите 8 годин
Я вважаю, що це може покращити вашу
концентрацію, коли ваш мозок працює добре,
ви дійсно можете звернути увагу на
деталі, і ваша пам'ять може бути кращою,
так точно, і це також покращує ваш
настрій, це дуже впливає на ваш настрій, тож
ви коли-небудь зустрічали примхливих студентів так, як
вчитель Я зустрів багато примхливих студентів,
вони приходять до класу, і ви не
знаєте причину їхнього настрою, чому
вони настроєні до них, ви знаєте, що
вони або грали в гру
онлайн, або спілкувалися  з
друзями або просто серфінгу в Інтернеті,
тому пам’ятайте, що гігієна сну може
покращити продуктивність, концентрацію,
пам’ять і настрій. Добре, тепер я
підготував для вас кілька технік медитації,
вони можуть допомогти вам виглядати, згадуючи
програми, щоб вони могли допомогти вам зі світлом
музику, і ви також можете медитувати або розслаблятися
перед сном під музику, вам також
потрібно бути дуже обережними, деяка
музика може бути дійсно зворушливою, тому ви
хочете танцювати, ви хочете встати і
продовжувати бути активними, поки інші
звуки допомагають вам  щоб розслабитися і заснути,
вау, я чув про це, але ніколи не
пробував, навчіть мене, будь ласка,
звісно,
те мені мішок, тому хлопці, будь ласка, сядьте зр
чніше, як усі гітари, закрийте оч
і послухайте музику, коли я пр
пиняю музику  ти збираєшся розповісти мені
свої почуття, що ти відчував,
коли слухав музику, готову, так що закрий
очі Ольга
[Музика]
добре, а тепер відкрий очі, так що ти прокинувся
, скажімо так, ти не був
спиш, але ти раптом відкриваєш очі
чому, Ольга, я сподівався, що це буде
щось дуже спокійне, але ці хвилі вони
мене налякали ці звуки вони мене налякали я
бачу, що щодо вас, хлопці, ви відчували те
саме, що я вам казав, що ви повинні бути дуже
обережними з  музика і загалом це
дуже розслабляє, але ці хвилі та
сила способів можуть бути страшними. Я погоджуюсь,
давайте спробуємо ще раз,
щоб ви розслабилися, закрийте очі і ви
слухали іншу музику,
готові, давайте,
Вонка, прокинься, я думаю, вам подобається ця
так, я майже заснув, було приємно і
тихо, і я думаю, що мій пульс
сповільнився, я бачу,
так що ця музика допомагає вам розслабитися, і ви
можете послухати таку музику перед тим, як піти
в бій, тому що вона легка, вона не
має сильних ударів  тож це допомагає тобі
піти до бити і заснути зараз я хочу, щоб
ти встав і подивись, з яких
сторін ти збираєшся встати,
чому ти запитав мене, є дуже відома
фраза, щоб вставати на  виворітна
сторона bat pro навіси над стартом і ста
ні, він каже, що це означає, що твій
день буде не дуже гарним, тому
все пішло не так, і ти кажеш, що я встав не з
того боку, тож чи був у тебе
такий досвід, так, є
дні, коли я відчуваю  я бачу не з того
боку ліжка, тому ми підготували
для вас відео, і я хочу, щоб ви всі
його подивилися першими, щоб ви переглянули відео
разом з нами і розповіли нам, що ви бачите, ви
розмовляєте зі своїм сусідом чи родичем
чи  твоїм друзям або просто до нас на
камеру, і ти скажеш мені добре,
тож ходімо о, я чую, як
будильник дзвонить,
чоловік встає з поганих речей він
одягає штани о ні, він
впав
о ні, фіранки підгоріли тост, знову нещастя
о ні його шарф о ні його намалювали,
його пограбували гаманець, його немає,
тепер
я думаю, що він запізнився, тепер
знову нещастя о ні, добре, що
жінка допомагає йому, так це виглядає
хлопець нещасний і нещасливий, ти згоден
зі мною так, я думаю, що він щойно встав
на неправильній стороні стрічки давайте подивимося,
що станеться, якщо він встане з
правого боку біти, тому я чую дзвіночок
, схоже, що він з іншого
боку біти,
тож він встає, він виходить, добре,
надіньте його  окуляри одягає штани,
він дивиться у вікно,
штори гарні, я бачу це, і
хліб дійсно хороший, він виглядає смачним, він
миє руки, і його виноградна лоза йде з
дому, а шарф у нього, тому все
добре, тепер хлопець  з ним все гаразд, тож його
гаманець у безпеці о, у нього фантастичне яблуко,
тож він їсть яблуко і
викидає це, мабуть, але чи
яблуко тримає іншого хлопця добре, боже мій,
це нещастя, яке
я бачу, скажи Боже, скажи, що це  інша
історія виглядає як дуже позитивна
чи ви згодні зі мною так, хлопці, ви
згодні добре зроблено, тож мені здається,
що нам потрібно закінчити урок, тож
вашим домашнім завданням буде написати,
що станеться з вами, якщо ви  встати на
неправильний бік і згадати про
правила сну
підготують вашу гігієну сну до сьогоднішнього сну так,
уникайте капризів, дотримуючись простих
правил, і до наступного разу
дякую вам за урок дякую всім
до побачення
[Музика]
ви